hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner tag
x
heute stehe ich nicht hinter meinem herz
sondern form einer küche denn heute
möchte ich euch meine küche zeigen die
ich eben vor kurzem gekauft habe ich
habe ganz viele anfragen dafür bekommen
ich solle endlich mal meine küche zeigen
also war ich praktisch schon gezwungen
dieses video zu drehen und heute möchte
ich euch kurz und knapp hoffentlich in
diesem video erzählen wie es zu diesen
küchenkauf kam was ich gut finde was ich
nicht gut finde
am ende des videos werde ich euch auch
ein paar tipps geben zu küchenkauf und
werde euch dann noch eine vorschau geben
was in nächster zeit an videos auf euch
zukommt ich bin frage ich nehme euch
jetzt einfach mal mit rein und seid euch
die einzelnen stationen erzählt euch
kurz was dazu und dann hört er eben die
vor und nachteile und eben auch in
partie 4 vielleicht besser machen könnte
wenn ich schon mal hier stehen möchte
ich einfach mal anfangen und ich sagen
wie ich die küche aufgeteilt haben
natürlich spielt jetzt bei mir viele
faktoren mit mir war es zum beispiel
wichtig dass ich eine küchen insel hat
und im hinteren bereich eben meine küche
ist und wir stehen hier in unserem in
unserer küche mein mann steht gerade im
wohnzimmer und wir haben hier unser
esszimmer das teile ich euch noch und
zwar war es mir wichtig dass ich noch
offene wohn ess gehabt weil ich ein
mensch bin ich stehe immer in der küche
auch wenn ich besuch habe dann möchte
ich mit meinen gästen unterhalten und es
gibt natürlich argumente die dagegen
sprechen zb sagen viele wenn man da
offene küche hat dann richtig ganze
wohnung nach essen oder wenn sie doch
mal dreckig ist dann sieht man dass
direkt ich will die tür zumachen und
dann habe ich einfach eine saubere
wohnung bei mir das ganze ein bisschen
anders ich habe ja gesagt ich stehe gern
ich arbeite gerne und werde mich
währenddessen mit meinen gästen
unterhalten ich arbeite auch so dass
meine küche eigentlich immer vorbei ist
also wenn dann vielleicht mal ein blech
rumsteht
weil wir gerade ss installiert haben
stattdessen hat weil ich eine lehre und
hier wohne aber ich arbeite eben auch
immer so dass ich immer mit meiner
arbeit auch auf räume also erkenntnisse
aus meinem
wenn ich ein rührteig gerührt habe um
den ofen steht dann habe ich ihnen
derzeit auch schon wieder meine
küchenmaschinen sauber gemacht und ich
bin so muss man aufarbeiten so ist es
effizient und das war mir wichtig dass
wir eine offene wohnküche haben und
deswegen auch die insel dass ich eben
immer mit dem blick darauf schauen kann
natürlich bei mir nicht anders weil ich
ja auch die videos für euch mache ich
wollte zum beispiel in der ganz weiße
küche ging dann nicht weil wir es
ausprobiert haben und in der weisen
küche werden mit dem hintergrund nicht
so schön geworden das war viel zu kalt
gewesen und deswegen haben wir uns auch
für dieses leichte grau entschieden und
für die graue arbeitsfläche weil man
soeben die ergebnisse viel besser sieht
und ein großes anliegen von mir war
natürlich dass ich ganz viel stauraum
habe und es war eigentlich nur das
hauptaugenmerk der küchenplanung dass
sich viele schubladen haben viele
schränke habe weil ich einfach
unglaublich viel werkzeug haben so sieht
die küche übrigens aus wenn abgedunkelt
ist also ich kann es nicht ganz dunkel
machen weil wir haben nur so schön
aussehen haben uns von fenstern und die
fenster sind sehr groß und es ist jetzt
einfach aus wenn wir gar kein licht an
haben ja oben in der küche habe ich
übrigens auch kein gelernter einfach
nichts passendes gefunden
hängt das habe hier rum und das ist
einfach ganz schön wenn wir diesen abend
wenn mal zwei tagen kann man hier in der
küche einfach so ein bisschen die
direkte sicht machen und zwar an habe
ich das einmal der arbeitsplatte und
einfach auch hier unten damit zwei
kerzen stehen und da haben wir da eben
nicht so direkt es nicht aber wenn man
sich zum beispiel man es nicht machen
will geht man einfach in die küche und
kann sich das dazu bereiten ohne dass
man im dunkeln steht weil die vom alltag
und jetzt ist es ein helm aber macht es
eben dunkel logisch und hier oben habe
ich meine dunstabzugshaube und daher
habe ich auch nicht ich weiß es nicht ob
ich von der seite aus aber es geht da
habe ich auch das nicht und zwar ist es
ein ganz schönes helles weiß es nicht
weil das dann direkt in die töpfe
geschaut und da hat man dann eben ein
besseres licht
das brauche ich eigentlich nur wenig
dass filme ansonsten ist sie immer schön
hell und das licht da hinten brauche ich
eigentlich echt relativ selten
ich zeige ich es einfach mal ganz kurz
meine aufteilung und zwar habe ich hier
meinen küchen insel mit einer
arbeitsplatte viel arbeitsplatz und
meinem ofen meinem hemd und darüber
meine dunstabzugshaube im hintergrund
könnt ihr eben die küchenzeile sehen
links ist ein kühlschrank ein kleiner
dem zeige ich euch später da hinten habe
ich meine hoch schränke in denen ich
eben stauraum habe darunter natürlich
das spülbecken und auch viel
arbeitsplatz um eben zum beispiel auch
sachen abzustellen
hier rechts habe ich meine zwei backöfen
zudem ich später noch was sagen
und weil dieser kühlschrank hier links
zu klein ist haben wir uns auch in
anderen küche
geholt und stellt einfach rechts neben
der küche und zwar ist es der
kühlschrank unterrichts ist die wohnung
aussagen was ich aber einfach so einer
entwicklung und dann mit neuen
kühlschrank eingestellt wie gesagt habe
ich hier die herdplatte und darüber eine
dunstabzugshaube
aber ich habe hier keine normale wahl
normalerweise hängen die er hier
herunter und ziehen dann direkt den
dampf weg das ging bei mir nicht weil
ich ja videos drehen um dann hätte ich
hier im gesicht
diese jungs haben deswegen haben wir so
einen decken lüfter da oben ist und ich
habe dafür eine fernbedienung hier in
der schublade
und hier kann ich dann eben das licht
einschalten oder eben dieses abzugshaube
bedienen
das hat jetzt keinen kanal nach draußen
einem ganz dicken filter drin und machte
neben die luft wieder rein und diesen
filter muss man immer mal wieder waschen
so alle zwei wochen und so wird es eben
hier dann mit der luft geregelt die
fernbedienung habe ich in meiner
schublade weil ich da einfach schnell
dran kommen kann und sie aber auch nicht
herum steht meine herzlich jetzt und
zwar habe ich ein induktionsherd gewählt
würde ich jetzt nicht mehr machen weil
ich für den induktionsherd jetzt auf
extra topf geschirr brauche mein altes
geschirr warnte den druck für uns
geeignet
jetzt habe ich mir ganz schnell
schneller blick auf die konten schlecht
sind die habe ich hier drin
übrigens zeige ich euch meine küchen
ordnung sind wie es eingerichtet hat man
anders und wenn ich zum beispiel einen
topf nehmen und den einschalter den
bedient man hier mit einem
touchscreen da bin ich noch so ein
bisschen gespaltener meinung als es ein
touchscreen markteinschätzung gerne weil
wir mal fertige hände hat dann geht es
nicht richtig aber ich habe auch eine
offerte geändert so dass man einfach
hier mit dass leitfunktion und ihr habt
das wahrscheinlich schon das mikrofon
dran also total das summen und es kommt
einfach daher da anscheinend
lufteinschlüsse in den töpfen sein
können und dann gibt's einfach diesen
hässlichen ton den ich absolut nicht
leiden kann und auch für haustiere
halten parteigänger die hören dass und
es kann eben ziemlich störend seien
vorteile von der infektions platte sind
einfach dass sie schneller erhitzen und
auch nicht reich werden also verreist
auch hinlangen und meine hand verbrennt
nicht aber meiner meinung nach ist
dieses summen und ganz großer nachteil
und eben auch das was man alles drum
geschert geben musste und jetzt ein ganz
neues feature waren richtig tollen blog
und da geht auch nicht und ich würde
glaube ich nicht mehr machen mit einer
induktionsplatte was ist auch ein
nachteil war
ich habe mir sachen volksanwaltschaft
verständliche tops diese steine sachen
und da gab es doch toll stein so eine
schale hat ist kommt man dann auch ein
herd legen und da etwas antrag und dann
in den backofen schieben
es geht bei mir auch nicht weil es nicht
auf reisen ist und wegen nicht
magnetisch was ich hier auch ganz
schlecht fing ist ja daran ich wollte
eigentlich dass die herdplatte in der
arbeitsplatte training dass ich
praktisch keinen übergang habt ihr heute
sind überall und ihr sehen
die sind ständig größer und kühe drin
und ich sitze also einem zahnstocher und
macht deshalb also man könnte natürlich
auch mit silikon abdichten
aber damit war hässlich aus und ja das
passende ein vergleich was ich hier an
der arbeitsplatte auch habe und das habe
ich mir so gewünscht
das war hier die arbeitsfläche weil ich
hier einfach meinen von dort aus rollen
kann und hier meine talken dekorieren
kann und einfach eine fläche haben die
groß genug ist um auch mal was großes
auszufallen
und deswegen habe ich hier so eine
holzfläche gewählt die man natürlich
auch pflegen muss mit holz pflegemitteln
ja und wenn ich hier natürlich arbeite
habe ich hier einfach mein back zubehör
habt ihr ganzen schubladen mit genug
stauraum hier seht ihr hier schon mal
die schubladen die ich hier drin habe
und hier habe ich etwas weniger platz
von der breite her und das haben wir
aber trotzdem genutzt hier habe ich zum
beispiel etwas nicht von oben nach unten
öffnet da habe ich habe zum beispiel
mein dekomaterial drin hab den kleinen
raum genutzt um das eben zu verstauen
und ihr seht hier auch zb das ist
qualitativ hochwertig ist mit diesen
zylindern hier hält man zb auch
klarmachen können aber so einfach wird
man ganz schön wirklich einfach nur
einmal drauf hier habe ich eine öffnung
da könnte ich jetzt zb auch so bleser
verstauen ich habe zwei kerzen drin weil
ich auch keine
denn von so viel bewegung macht mir hier
fehlt aber noch die klatsche zum
abstecken also das wurde falsch
eingebaut und das fehlt hier noch und
unten habe ablehnt ausgenutzt und zwar
ist es eine schublade die keinen griff
hat sondern ich drücke einfach drauf und
dann kommt er raus und da habe ich jetzt
im moment meine ausstecher drin und fand
so eigentlich wenigen handgriffen die
schubladen öffnen und wieder schließen
das ist natürlich mein haupt
arbeitsplatz und deswegen habe ich hier
auch am rand zwei steckdosen
ich finde es allerdings besser wenn man
die steckdosen mit auf der arbeitsplatte
hat deshalb meine freundin zu hause und
zwar existiert und so eine öffnung für
kreis und dann drückt betraut und dann
fährt seine schubladen leisten so eine
steckdosenleiste hoch aber kanada alles
einstecken und einfach wieder weg
schieben
hier kann es nämlich passieren wenn man
zum beispiel nehmen wir mal an
verletzten stabmixer mit kabel müsste
ich denn hier anschließen und bis zu
meinem topf rüber wird es gar nicht
reichen
deswegen habe ich zum beispiel in
stabmixer ohne kabel und deswegen klappt
das bei mir super aber hier schließt
sich dann zum beispiel meine
küchenmaschinen an dieser seite habe ich
natürlich auch über alle schubladen drin
und zwar das habe ich hier jemals drei
kleine und drei flache weil es jedoch
ein ganzes werkzeug verstauen kann dann
habe ich auch so schubladen einen sekt
zusätzlich gekauft das ganze hier
verstaut und aber auch hier unten große
schubladen um auch große sachen zu
verstauen
ja und ich finde gerade wir mal hier
arbeitet brauchen schubladen wenn man
jetzt hier türen hätte müsste die öffnen
dann stehen hier in deckung und deswegen
ist in schubladen wie immer besser und
ich kann das hier schon verstauen
hier seht ihr schon ich habe hier genug
platz zu arbeiten das heißt auch wenn
hinter einer spülmaschine aufmachen
habe ich immer noch pflanzen und dem
platz braucht ihr aber auch also habe
ich weiß nicht genau wie viel habe ich
glaube das sind 1 meter und den platz
braucht ihr wenn ich zum beispiel hier
steht ihr könnt jetzt schnell man auch
noch am herd was machen oder eben
umgekehrt
hier will gründen habe ich mein spiel
becken was ich abgrundtief hassen und
zeige ich euch auch wieso und zwar ist
das einst aus edelstahl
ich wollte eigentlich 1 aus einem
anderen material
mein mann wollte unbedingt edelstahl und
jetzt kann ich euch einmal die nachteile
einen schlechten edelstahl spülbecken
zeigen und zwar ich sag jetzt einfach
auch die marke dazu weil wir die marke
absolut nicht gefällt das ist die marke
ticker wie auch meine backöfen und mein
herz mtk ist eine hausmarke von büchern
studio und ich habe diese zeit gewählt
weil es natürlich auch eine kostenfrage
war und wir uns einfach mal hier für
etwas günstigeres entschieden haben
aber das würde ich nicht mehr machen ich
finde gerade an den geräten darf man
echt nicht sparen weil man dann einfach
unglücklich mit
hier stellt sich zum beispiel total dass
ich ständig kalkflecken habe ich habe
ständig verfärbungen
wir treten zum beispiel viel schwarztee
und dann klebt man das hier eben aus und
so weiter ich habe eben mal verfärbungen
muss immer mit scheuer mails oder sogar
mit mit seinem bleichmittel 3 damit es
überhaupt wieder hell wird und das finde
ich total schrecklich und ich putze es
wahrscheinlich drei mal am tag mit
scheuer wind weil einfach ständig nach
jedem gebrauch spiel flecken entstehen
und wasserflecken und es ist einfach ein
ganz großer nachteil was mich hier auch
stadt ist das spiel decke nicht tief
genug ist also dass ich jetzt von der
höhe her
reicht mir das einfach nicht weil ich
zum beispiel auch große backwaren haben
und backformen habe und es mir einfach
schwer fällt hier zu waschen und dass
die armatur passt hier einfach mit ihnen
also das hätte natur sein müssen sie
etwas höher ist auch mit seinem auszug
das erleichtert mir auch das
saubermachen wenn man hier die armatur
nehmen kann und diese duschkopf hier
sauber machen kann und so eine armatur
seiner kleinen da würde ich nicht mehr
wären also ja das hat sich für uns als
nicht so gut erwiesen
ich mache es einfach jetzt hier unten
weiter und zwar habe ich unter meinem
spülbecken so eine schublade die
normalerweise betätigt wird indem man
drauf drückt aber teilchen mir das teilt
abgefahren
dies ist also eigentlich drückt man den
fuß drauf und dann geht gibt es die
schublade von alleine auf aber das ist
irgendwie raus gegangen und da kam es
noch keine um das zu reparieren
aber das wird wieder eingesetzt und dann
geht es von alleine auf das hat den
vorteil wenn ich jetzt zum beispiel
gemüse oder obst waschen und putzen
drücke ich da mit meinem gusto auf das
öffnet sich und dann kann ich einfach
alles hier in meinen mülleimer schmeißen
und das sind wir eigentlich auch direkt
in diese schublade drin
hier habe ich einfach meine
reinigungsmittel hier oben eine spürbare
die ich immer braucht und da ist echt
super wenn ich oben arbeiter und das
abspiel einfach mehr fuß drücken muss
und es dann einfach raus holen kann und
ich erste schublade im aufmachen muss
hier habe ich einfach tragen will einmal
behälter in einem sammle ich immer mein
glas das haben wir alles schon geleert
und die anderen zwei habe ich würde
und da finde ich es dürfen auch nichts
für großes nehmen weil das riecht ja mit
der zeit deswegen lieber jeden tag mit
rausbringen und
hat mal jemand angerufen und außerdem
hat man dann jeden tag eine
beschäftigung für den mann also kann es
eigentlich macht spaß ist auch so dass
müll rausbringen immer so eine menge
arbeit ist was anderes wort für
schmeicheln
ja und ich mache das auch gar nicht es
gibt es in rot das macht mein mann macht
das ist bis jetzt nicht morgen mussten
ja da ist eben wie gesagt so dass
reinigung ist zeuge ich ignoriere ich
einfach mein mann
hier habe ich direkt die spülmaschine
hätte ich jetzt nicht öffnet denn ihr
könnt hier unten sehen
da ist gerade ein rotes licht das heißt
die spülmaschine läuft gerade und zu der
sagt ich deswegen später was aber man
hört sie gar nicht wie ihr
wahrscheinlich festgestellt habt und das
kommt daher weil ich die schule maschine
ausgetauscht habe ich hatte am anfang
nämlich ein ganz schreckliches modell
aber dazu sagen dass später was wenn ich
euch die spülmaschine zeigen hier weiter
habe ich auch wieder auszüge in denen
ich jetzt leider noch kein system habe
und zwar brauche ich noch mal ein system
für ihnen drin als für die schupp machen
und zwar habe ich als sehr große
schubladen wie ihr sehen könnt und ich
brauchte einfach abtrennungen wo ich
damit zb täglich verstauen kann und
schüssel füllen damit die nicht ständig
umfang und um jetzt zu den großen fladen
zu kommen
also ich bin jetzt kein fan von euch
marken ist sondern ich sage ich jetzt
einfach ich habe mir eine schmidt küche
gekauft weil die schmidt küchen ein
passus in das der tiefer sind also ich
habe keine 60 cm sondern habe 75 cent
älter hab dich wegen mehr arbeitsfläche
als eine größere arbeit vielleicht ja
was für mich optimal ist weil ich viel
brauche und ich habe natürlich viel mehr
stauraum
das kommt daher weil sie nicht nur
breiter sind sondern auch höher als ich
jetzt sowieso egal welche küche ich
genommen hatte eine hohe küche gebracht
wenn 90 cm gross will und andy schmidt
küchen sind nicht nur breit sondern auch
sehr hoch und deswegen sehen die
schubladen eben auch riesengroß
ich sage ich das jetzt einfach mal so
recht ungeordnet aber ihr seht ihr dann
dies optimiert
wenn ich mein schuh planungssystem habe
und zwar brauche ich einfach was
um das alles abzutrennen
hier habe ich noch eine innen schublade
und da kann ich dann eben kleinere
sachen abstellen
hier ist eine flasche und das ist
einfach super hier nochmal den stauraum
nutzt weil diesen stauraum da wird mir
nichts mehr rein stellen und so haben
wir insgesamt weil den schnitt küchen 66
prozent mehr platz weil man eben die
breite hat die höhe und dann auch die
zwischen schubladen und das war einfach
für mich ein hauptargument seiner küche
zu nehmen weil ich für mich einfach das
stahlross sei wichtig war
auf der anderen seite ist deswegen zeige
ich euch das nicht
hiermit wollen ein neuer kühlschrank und
bevor wir es öffentlich jedoch den platz
den wir genutzt haben um hier einfach so
kleinere gerade ein zu machen habe ich
jetzt total leider koche backbücher drin
und in großer 200 leider nicht
reingepasst aber ich muss sowieso mal
ausrichten
hier habe ich einfach meinen kleinen
einbau kühlschrank und zwar war der uns
zu klein deswegen haben wir auch zwei
und den hier wird sich einfach für meine
vorrangig habe hier meine eier immer
drin meine saft mein wasser zum beispiel
ich habe hier meine ganzen sahne und
milchprodukte aus den anderen
kühlschrank eben zum täglichen gebrauch
und unten habe ich noch so drei gefriert
fächer und das hätte uns einfach nicht
mal im alltäglichen leben gereicht
stellte vorteil der große torte ich habe
die älter wird heute gemacht und ich
habe hier nichts x 50 cm also das sind
40 zentimeter maximal und da passt
einfach gar nichts hier seht ihr meine
hoch schränke ich habe jetzt viel hoch
schreibt also auch viel platz
ich habe fast bis unter die decke machen
lassen aber natürlich nicht dann nicht
das aussieht und ich habe die schränke
so gewählt dass wir nach oben aufgehen
und wollte auch dass die nach oben auf
gehen weil man so einfach erst muss ich
den kopf nicht anbrennt das mache ich
nämlich immer ganz gerne
und zweitens stehen sie danach schnell
weg kommen das heißt wenn ich das
arbeite kann ich dir einfach mal offen
lassen und dann immer wieder was
rausholen jetzt habe ich gerade das
kicken meiner spielten maschine gehört
das heißt ich kann sie jetzt noch nicht
fertig da habe ich jetzt hier in der
spülmaschine dies sei viel platz im
innern hat weil sie viel stauraum hat
die spülmaschine die ich vorher hatte
die war so schlecht dass ich unten hier
in diesem besteck corp nicht einmal
meine teilnahme oder diese dinge rein
stellen konnte
weil es dann so hoch war dass sich das
hier nicht mehr gedreht hat und habe ich
bin fast wahnsinnig geworden wir haben
die spülmaschine drei mal einschalten
müssen bis überhaupt was sauber wurde
es lag nicht an den spielt hat es lag
einfach in der maschine und bei mir
vereinfachte decke roche faktor noch
sonst gesunde sache meine alte
spülmaschine war auch sehr laut und
diese hier die hat war eigentlich kaum
als ich kann die auch mal laufen lassen
wenn ich ein video drehen und ich hab
jetzt eigentlich das piepen gehört und
die ist echt super weil sie auch die
knöpfe hier im inneren hat das heißt die
verschickten wenn ihr es zu machen und
samira kann nicht herkommen und mir
wieder die einstellung verdrehen das man
hat wenn ihr mich in der küche ihrer
gemacht jetzt zeige ich euch noch hier
meine rückwand und zwar habe ich hier
eine rückwand aufs parkett
normalerweise mit meiner rückwände aus
glas oder milchglas oder plexiglas damit
macht er einfach sauber machen kann
aber ich arbeite hier im hintergrund
auch fast nix also mein herz ist nicht
da deswegen kann zum beispiel keine
tomatensuppe an die wand spritzen und
deswegen war es nicht wichtig ob es
leicht zu reinigen ist oder nicht
sondern ich wollte einfach dass die
parkett wird man zum boden herbst da
haben wir nämlich auch im paket und
natürlich auch zu meiner arbeitsplatte
an der insel und ihr meine
arbeitsflächen sind grundsätzlich leer
weil es ja immer
schön abwischen will und deswegen steht
bei mir auch außer bei einer
küchenmaschine außerdem beiden nichts
herum weil ich auch sonst nichts jeden
tag im kraut gebraucht habe das heißt
ich habe zum beispiel keine toaster hier
stehen weil wir kann jeden jeden tag
trost essen
ich habe dann was da kommen noch da um
eine brotbox weil die eigentlich so
jeden tag im einsatz sind aber ansonsten
ist die fläche eberl er damit ich
während dem kochen einfach platz genug
habe und da meine sache eben abstellen
kann
ich wollte eigentlich die rücklagen
komplett leer leisten habe dann gehe ich
brauche doch auch zum aufhängen zum
beispiel hierfür mein spülmittel was ich
immer hier abfüllen
ich habe mir nämlich jemand sich sehr
nach wildparks die sind erstens
günstiger und zweitens an speicher für
die verpackungs würde weil ich dann
einfach große nachbar packs nehme und
ist dann immer wieder da rein machen
kann und außerdem ist die dosierung viel
einfacher da drückt man einfach drauf
und es kommt raus und ich muss nicht
dass sie die anliegen und ausschöpfen
deswegen steht jetzt hier oben damit
hier unten lakers frei hat und hier habe
ich einfach so mein wichtigstes werkzeug
hingehängt das ist übrigens ein system
von ikea
ich finde so systeme sind ja ganz gut
weil es immer so praktisch ist die
arbeit nicht so dass auch wenig platz
viel vertrauen können und deswegen haben
wir hier dieses system geholt mit dem
haken die man überall ihnen hängen kann
ich habe zum beispiel auch meine töpfe
bei ikea gekauft aber die finde ich
absolut nicht gut weil sie einfach sie
sind einfach günstig war günstig und
sind auch gänzlich verarbeitet also da
kann sie jetzt nicht mit hochklassigen
töpfen vergleichen
nicht nur wegen dem geräuschpegel was
selben entsteht wenn ich es auf dem herd
ab sondern auch wegen der reinigung
wegen der hand habe und die sind immer
heiß und ich will dort eigentlich muss
systeme holen wenn sich das anbietet
aber zum beispiel werkzeug wie mein
küchenwerkzeug oder vorratsdosen und
unwillig oder ton weil für mich solche
sachen nachhaltig und langfristig
einfach leben müssen und deswegen
einfallslosen zum beispiel das zeige ich
euch aber in einem anderen video lege
ich dann zum beispiel wert darauf dass
die gut sind weil was sie ja ständig
öffnen und schließen muss und wenn man
da nicht drauf achtet auf die qualität
kann es sein dass die decke kaputt gehen
und dann hat es einfach folgekosten
ich habe zwei backöfen dann werdet ihr
auch über oft danach gefragt elisa hast
du zwei backöfen oder die frage wieso
hast du jetzt plötzlich zwei oder drei
küchenmaschinen und ihr braucht es
natürlich nicht aber ich mache auch
wieder videos die ich mache es so viel
dass ich halte meine küchenmaschinen
brauche ich war richtig getestet habe
und weil ich einfach parallel oft vieles
gleichzeitig mache meine zwei backöfen
brauche ich war nicht eben auch die para
es ist für mich einfach zeit sparen und
ihr waren natürlich keine zweifel
aber es zeigt ihr euch nicht üblich sind
die auch von tk und ich bin zufrieden
und ich sage euch jetzt was ich schlecht
finde und tauschte dann machen sich dem
nicht aus wenn ich gute fakten gefunden
habe was ich nicht schlecht findet sind
die knöpfe thema eben verdrehen kann und
wie er rein drücken kann
aber es gibt mittlerweile auch offen
ohne knöpfe und ihn vorzeitig weil
erstens mal finde ich die knöpfe die
wackeln hat immer und ich mag es auch
nicht also dieses ständige rein und raus
aufdrehen
das hauptargument gegen diese knöpfe ist
ich kann meine temperatur nicht genau
einstellen
also ich weiß weder was jetzt 50 grad
sind 90 grad 200 grad ich kann's nicht
einstellen
es hat keine die ist komm mal her ich
weiß es nicht ich der strich jetzt 50
oder ich das jetzt zwischen 50 und 90
habe ich jetzt so 90 keine ahnung
das wichtige ist auch jede verarbeitung
ihr seht zum beispiel hier die spaltmaße
die hier stimmen und was ich ehrlich
gesagt mit macht und ich frage mich auch
wie so manches macht wieso hier so einen
spalt drin ist sollte es eigentlich für
mich noch spart indem sich staub abt sap
aber ansonsten hat das für mich kein
grund also ich finde das hätte man auch
ganz zumachen können
und hier habe ich zwar alle funktionen
als ich habe hier ober und unterhitze
umluft heißluft grill unter hitze und
europa jetzt der kühlfunktion ich finde
es braucht man eigentlich in jedem haus
meine allererste küche in der ersten
wohnung wisst ihr ja ich hatte einen
ofen der oberen interesse und ich bin
damit fünf jahre ausgekommen
aber natürlich ist für mich jetzt
perfekt wenn ich auf umluft oder 1 doch
gehabt
zum beispiel auch dem thema unter meinen
ofen habe ich auch den platz genutzt um
staumauern zu schaffen
deswegen auch die einzigen schränke mit
den türen die ebenso nach außen aufgehen
ich es nicht mehr machen ich will das
nächste mal ab hier auszüge machen hier
aber ich habe zum beispiel
entsprechendes werkzeug drin was ich
darin verstaut habe es steht alles noch
irgendwie ungeordnet und ich brauche das
system zu retten und es geht einfach
schwierig in so schränken als ich jetzt
lieber austreten könnte dazu wollte
meine fläche rheinstein und herausnehmen
hier muss ich jetzt zum beispiel ist
zwar für alle zimmer rausnehmen das
blech rausholen oder das gitter und ja
ich bin einfach nicht optimal
zum beispiel habe ich hier meinen
gesamten stein produkte und man muss
immer aufpassen dann herausziehen das
nichts unterstellen ist und auch da
hätte ich eben das leber im sommer die
sonne schon veraltet wenn durch braucht
und wie kann und einfach alles
rausnehmen kann was ich hier nicht mag
sollte mit der qualität nichts zu tun
sondern ich hasse diese grippe ich
wollte eigentlich eine küche ohne griffe
und irgendwie hat man mir dann dass ihr
angedreht
ich finde mich nicht dass obendrauf der
griff ständig verstaubt weil verfällt
immer mal wieder unsere sachen runter
oder beim kochen hier auf diese
schublade und ich hatte eigentlich keine
lust hier ständig diese leiste hier
abzustauben
jetzt ist es halt so und ich las es so
aber normalerweise mag ich gerne küchen
ohne griff und ich habe vorhin noch
vergessen zu erwähnen dass er meine von
max sind also nicht hochladen
ich wollte ursprünglich hochtouren es
ging aber nicht wegen der kamera und
licht weil es dann immer spiegelt
deswegen habe ich mal küchen und auch
hier habe ich das problem mit den
griffen was sich hier dass staub wieder
absetzt und ich das absolut nicht mag
wenn man da so eine rille drin hat und
jetzt zeige ich euch einfach nur kurz
meinen kühlschrank und zwar wollten wir
so ein zeitweiser also einen mit zwei
türen
es gibt ja welche die haben rechts und
kühlschrank und links den gefrierschrank
war uns aber dann zu klein weil man so
dann einfach weniger platz hat dann
hätte ich ein gefrierfach was muss so
breit ist und kühlschrank der so breit
ist und deswegen habe ich einen
kühlschrank gewählt eben mit zwei tür
zeigt euch gleich will euch aber auch
kurz die front zeigen und zwar habe ich
hier einfach die digitalanzeige
da steht die temperatur drauf und die
kann auch ich einstellen also warum 8
grad im kühlschrank und -18 im
gefrierfach und viele kühlschränke haben
ja noch ein paar fotos würfel rauskommen
oder wo man dann hinten zum beispiel
auch ein
wasser einfüllen kann usw wollten wir
nicht weil wir einfach nicht so die
eiswürfel trinker sind und so
kaltgetränke wenn dann habe ich dann
mein wasser im kühlschrank oder eben
hinten oder ich nehme einfach die
eiswürfel aus dem fach und dieser
kühlschrank ist echt super weil der
einfach groß ist ich konnte da meine lkw
torte komplett einstellen
er hat über 60 cm als ich glaubte hat
sogar 70 75 vielleicht auch 80 ich weiß
es ehrlich gesagt nicht genau
und ich habe hier einfach unsere sachen
drin das zeige ich euch aber im
organisations video ebenso tägliche
sache frühstücks sachen obst gemüse hier
habe ich zum beispiel das sieht man hier
durch mein obst und gemüse und da ist
hinten zum blaues licht drin und es
hilft einfach dass das obst und gemüse
länger frisch bleibt und nicht so
schnell geben erklärt deswegen haben wir
das hier gemacht und side by side
kühlschrank mit diesen zwei türen wo man
eben einen kühlschrank hat nennt man
übrigens brennstoff der papst jetzt weil
ich in länger als eine minute offen
hatte und habe ich nicht einfach sondern
habe zwei kleine kühlfächer deshalb
meine küche und ich zeit mich jetzt
einfach mal gegensätzlich dazu noch eine
andere küche und nehme ich jetzt einfach
mal mit ihr bin ich jetzt zum beispiel
in der küche in der ich euch einiges
zeiten kann dass die küchen von einem
freund von man und zwar ist auch eine
kleine küche also man kann es jetzt
nicht mit unserer küche vergleichen dass
ich es mir so eine studentin küche
einfach klein eine kochstelle im
spülbecken übersteigen könne und ich
möchte auch gar nicht diese küche mit
meinem vergleichen sondern einfach die
einzelnen elemente
hier kam zum beispiel erkennen dass
schon die schränke anders denn die hoch
schränke an zu diesem türen die nach
außen aufgehen und hier zum beispiel mit
janine festgemacht sind und diese über
beispielsweise geschotterten aufplatzen
weil das nicht richtig eingestellt wurde
und es hier dran und so führen zum
beispiel wollte ich dahin gar nicht weil
ich eben mal jemand den ich frag mich
dann gerne mal den kopf waren und
deswegen keine dem titel irgendwann oben
nicht zur seite
ich bleibe gerade hier stehen wir mal
der duft nach zu haben weiter und war es
eben solchen satz habe ich seht ich bin
und meter 76 groß 75 und ich bin so
konnte das da habe ich mir auch immer
gerne den kopf einmal aber man hat die
seien nämlich auch so
und die hängt einfach tief und ich will
dann vielleicht ein topf gucken und dann
sturz mit dem kopf an
und die müssen einfach so hängen weil
nämlich der abstand ist ihr nicht zu
hoch sein darf weil unseren die
dunstabzugshaube gar nichts bringt da
gibt es aber auch lösungen das ist eben
die dunstabzugshaube dann an der wand
gibt das tanzbein bis eine scheibe die
ist nach oben so ein bisschen raus und
da habe man sich dann nicht dem kopf
voran wurde select den jugendlichen
genau welche die sind direkt hier
da gibt es dann so zu spalten und dann
zieht es die luft also diesen dampf und
alles möglich alles darunter das gibt es
auch aber die sind natürlich relativ
treu als ich glaube sogar dass ein
4000 euro gekostet hatte und da haben
wir uns absolut gar keine lösung
deswegen haben wir bei uns diesen denken
lufterfrischer oder luft wie sagt man
dann ab zum song die die abzusaugen
da kann man hier an der front ganz gut
sehen als sie das in vier farbige freund
und da ist es wahr dass die diesen
angespannten hier sieht man das ist zum
beispiel hier schon bricht also da wird
hier auch irgendwann weg gehen
hier ist das spiel auch so egal ob jetzt
ein wasserkocher zb hier habt oder auch
der wasserdampf aus dem topf kommt da
kommt immer ein bisschen in den
schränken und deswegen müssen so fronten
immer ganz gut frisiert sein und da
macht es eben bemerkbar
spätestens jetzt hier schon spätestens
nach drei vier monaten wird ihm das hier
nach brüssel
und man kann auch einen daumen übergeben
also muss ich schon dass es nicht mehr
klappt und ich finde da darf man
entspannen weil das einfach folgekosten
ab dann haben wir hier das waschbecken
und ich meine man sieht auf den ersten
blick dass sich männer haushalte da ist
nicht so sauber wie bei einer frau
wobei ich jetzt keine männer hier in die
diskriminierenden es gibt auch sehr
saubere männer aber die sich aus und
edelstahl war strecken und
schon die flecken und ich mag es auch
bei mir zu hause in hat er sich
allerdings auf das war ständig ist nicht
tief genug
wir haben jetzt mal ganz kleines mal
sprechen also da kann man vielleicht
mehr einführen und was kleines waschen
aber beim großen wird schon schwieriger
das wasser tropfte alles nach außen und
man kann hier auch sehen der handwerker
der hier mal da das absolut nicht gut
gemacht denn die silikon vogel also ihr
seht hier erstens mehr hier ist sie
kaputt und zweitens mal hier dieser shop
feuchtigkeit und dadurch wird einfach
die arbeitsplatte feucht die
arbeitsplatte gilt von hinten auch weil
es auch mit dem sparkonto ethikerin die
rückwand stets kaputt und das heißt die
küche liegt eigentlich nicht mal ein
jahr denkt ich ja weil das leider nicht
gut verarbeitet wurde
hier haben wir zum beispiel die
spülmaschine also über das innere wenig
gar nicht sprechen kann er ganz normales
spiel passt denke ich alles rein sie
hier auch nicht ganz hoch also das ist
zum beispiel so ein modell nicht daheim
erzählt hatte so wie ich vorher hatte
das ist zu tief ist und nicht mal meine
tragschrauber reingepasst haben als ich
dann das nicht mehr drehen konnte aber
was ich hier nur zeigen und hier sind
die knapp für ausnahmen gemacht für den
haushalt keine kinder hat ist alles okay
aber ich zum beispiel habe dass amira
und jetzt irgendwann den knappen raum
gedrückt und zwar dann natürlich total
blöd wenn du die spülmaschine einstellst
einschaltet und dann kommt irgendwann
ein kind vorbei drückt und dann geht
entweder die schule maschine an oder aus
und er sich natürlich nicht so gut ich
kann mal sehen die unterschränke sind
auch eigentlich nur so schränke zu
eröffnen
und hier sehen wir zum beispiel kann ich
unter den bau stecken empfiehlt sich
immer ein auszug zu haben weil man
weniger wahrscheinlich hier im nacken
wurde dann ist alles rausholen und da
hinten dran zu kommen
ich habe den auszug ich hole eines
raumes kam von oben rein gucken und es
starten jetzt zeitweilig nicht jedes mal
alles um kostenlos und einfach gucken
muss ständig jetzt verdienen und was
steht nach hinten
wir hatten ausflugs
also ich sehe ich konnte sich für mich
die art traum muss da gehe ich hatte
vorher auch nicht gesehen weil man am
ende davon erzählt aber es ist recht das
vorführmodell müssen wir wieder bei den
fronten und zwar bei diesen schränke
neben ihr hier genau ob man die töpfe
zum beispiel da muss man wenigstens
einen topf nudeln kochen ist dahin
unserer macht das heißt ich muss jetzt
erstmal die pfannen rausholen dann den
topf dann wieder einräumen und das ganze
bei einem schuber schienenausbau wieder
und deswegen schon ausdruck über besser
ich gucke von oben rein und fertig aber
was ich hier eigentlich gut aber hier
der mars abstand da ihr seht die türen
und diese familie
neben ihrer arbeit das einzustellen die
tür bist du eigentlich so hängen und
eigentlich auch weiter nach rechts und
dann wird's gut hängen aber jetzt mal
einfach das wird ja mit der zeit wieder
hängen also dann kannst einstellen carla
bestimmt auch gemacht am anfang und dann
irgendwann weil wir ständig auf und legt
sich sowieso darunter kleidung
hier hat der backofen der auf eben unter
dem herd ist früher standard aber für
mich war es ein no-go weil ich bugs so
viel und ich habe mich ständig runter
begrüßen wieder hoch oder runter sowieso
putzen ist das eine absolute katastrophe
weil es so putzen kann das ja offen oder
muss man rein und ich habe da ständig
wachsenden sollte deswegen bin ich froh
dass ich meine nicht von oben habe auf
augenhöhe oder hat ihn in meiner
wirklich stehen kann und auf jeden fall
ist es viel angenehmer
was ich hier ganz cool tier wird das
habe ich zu hause nicht und zwar sind
diese apotheke schränkte weil wir da
einfach von beiden seiten gut ankommt da
kann man gut gehört zu unserer verstauen
vorräte also da könnte zum beispiel die
täterin noch ein mehl zucker und so
weiter ich bräuchte dann natürlich einen
größeren weil ich viele vor ich habe
aber ihr könnt noch so dieses wichtigste
reim machen und da gibt es auch menschen
die da hier durchsichtig seine finde ich
besser weil man dann auch vielleicht mal
kleiner sondern drin hat die man von der
seite
aber es ist nicht gedacht und ist ja
schon ein klarer denke ich vielleicht
einen rein passt aber in zukunft wird es
auf jeden fall wieder und haben hier
jetzt den kühlschrank und auch hier
sieht man wieder das stimmt natürlich
nicht immer alles gut einstellen müssen
hier ist es ist so dass wir eine gefühlt
gefriert kühl kombi haben wo oben dann
das kühlfach ist das dreckige körper von
hinten der kühlschrank der kühlschrank
und da ich ziemlich weit unten also wenn
man da ins gemüsefach will muss man da
ziemlich weit darunter
wir haben gottes schattenmänner
kühlschrank war seine dafür 1
freilandhaltung das ist schon mal gut
das ist ja ich denke zu dieser küche war
eigentlich genug gesagt natürlich kann
man die zwei küchen also diese küchen
von unserem freund und meine kämpfe
jetzt nicht vergleichen ist natürlich
ein preislicher unterschied ich kann ja
auch keinen viert mit einem mercedes
vergleichen aber ich wollte ich einfach
mal die verarbeitungs unterschiede
zeigen es macht sowas brauchen
unterschied ob ich jetzt eine küche für
mich kaufe für mein haus für meine
wohnung oder ob ich zum beispiel in
miete wohne und weiß in 25 jahren sich
wieder aus also man muss immer wissen
investiertes geld oder investors nicht
unsere küche habe ich ihnen im
küchenstudio gekauft wir waren auch
vorher in dem möbelhaus und haben uns da
beraten lassen
es war ein großes möbelhaus kennt ihr
auch alle und ich habe mich dann dagegen
entschieden und dann bin ich eben zu
einem küchenstudio gegangen was bei uns
regional ist vor ort und habe mir das
angehört die machen auch nur küchen und
dass ich einfach ein großer unterschied
gewesen weil ich weiß die stellen nur
küchen her planen den ganzen tag nichts
anderes als küchen und kennen sich damit
aus meiner erfahrung weiß auch dass das
küchenstudio vor ort nicht teurer war
ein großes möbelhaus das stellen sich
wahrscheinlich viele so vor küchenstudio
teurer
aber das ist gar nicht so aus unterm
strich bin ich sogar wahrscheinlich
etwas günstiger raus gekommen weil es
individuell auf mich zugestimmt wurde
und ich zeige euch jetzt einfach mal und
gebt euch einfach mal noch ein paar
tipps zum küchenkauf und vielleicht
helfen die euch ja ein bisschen weiter
der erste tipp den ich verstehen kann
macht euch schon mal gedanken darüber
wie viel geld er überhaupt ausgeben
wollt sagen wir mal ihr wollt oder ihr
könnt 8000 euro für die küche ausgeben
dass es ein budget dann sagt dem
küchenhersteller ich kann 6000 abgeben
auch die acht kommt ist sowieso weil
dann immer noch was einfällt dass man
sagt es muss noch mit rainer dieses muss
noch mit rein und deswegen würde ich
generell eher den niedrigeren preis
sagen denn teurer wird immer niedriger
wird eigentlich nicht es kommt dann
wahrscheinlich meistens so dass ihr sagt
ich gebe 8000 euro aus sagt es dem
küchenhersteller am ende seid ihr bei zu
sehen und dann heißt okay vielleicht
nämlich doch die günstigere stühle oder
die günstigere armatur und dann spart
ihr an den falschen ecken also setzt
lieber übers tiefer an und das wird von
alleine etwas teurer und küchen die
gibts echt von einem kleinen budget ab
bis zu einem hohen ich kann 100.000 euro
für eine küche zahlen oder auch nur
10.000 oder nur 4000 mein tipp nummer
zwei in seriöser küchen verkäufer der
wird euch auch sagen dass er die geräte
auch gerne woanders kochen können zu
einem günstigeren preis in dem freund
von uns ist es nämlich so passiert er
hat im internet natürlich nachgeschaut
nach küchengeräten natürlich sind die im
internet günstiger und er wollte doch
bestellen und die küche die er gekauft
hat bei einem möbelhaus hätte er nicht
kaufen dürfen ohne geräte ein seriöser
hersteller wird jetzt sagen okay ich
verkaufe euch die küche an den geräten
verdiene ich sowieso nicht so viel kauft
die geräte woanders ich empfehle ich
aber trotzdem die geräte bei einem
fachmann zu kaufen und nicht im internet
ich habe im internet schon ein bisschen
meine erfahrungen macht mit großgeräten
als ich will keinen herd oder offen
oder sonst irgendwas im internet kaufen
sondern wird da eben zu einem fachmarkt
gehen und es dort holen und wir haben
unsere 2000 küchenstudio wie gesagt
kleidete küchenstudio marke aber das war
so mein zweiter tipp einfach mit den
seriösen küchen verkäufer mein nächster
tief ist lasst euch nicht unter druck
setzen
ich kenne so oft vermessen dass es dann
heißt unterschreibt heute denn nur heute
gibt es dieses angebot und auch viele
küchenhersteller oder möbelhäuser machen
das so die dann sagen unterschreibt
heute
ansonsten verfällt das die aktion oder
so und deswegen lasst euch nicht unter
druck setzen überlegt zu hause noch mal
und überlegt was möchte ich wie möchte
ich es von wem wenig ihr braucht euch
von keine petzen und von keinem drängeln
lassen
mein nächster tipp ist ihr sollt handeln
und zwar sind gerade bei küchen oder
auch anderen möbelstücken sehr hohe
gewinnmargen drin deswegen informiert
euch gut über die preise und oftmals ist
es so dass es zum beispiel den teuren
marken hersteller gibt und der verkauf
seiner marke saab und der gleiche
hersteller verkauft die gleiche küche
und einem günstigeren name viel
günstiger deswegen informiert euch da
über die marken und pendelt einfach und
mein nächster tipp zahlt nemours den
vollen betrag auf einmal im voraus wir
haben den fehler gemacht weil wir gesagt
haben wir wollen uns weghaben dann ist
die küche abgezahlt und ich kann meinen
kopf frei haben für anderes es war
wahrscheinlich unser großer fehler dass
wir bis heute noch vier monate nach als
möglichen kauf immer noch auf sachen
warten wie zum beispiel die
innenausstattung ich jetzt im nachhinein
so gemacht die anzahlung gemacht und
dann erst den kompletten betrag ab und
wenn alles da steht also das musst du
echt immer als druckmittel einfach
benutzen
und falls auch nicht auf angebote rein
wie zum beispiel aus prospekten von
möbelhäusern oder auch aus dem internet
wenn das spiel steht zb steht dieser
krise gibt es für dieses angebot dann
hat es meistens den haken dass ich sie
genau wie abgebildet nehmen muss
wahrscheinlich noch ohne geräte und
sobald ihr nicht klitzekleine änderungen
bis zum beispiel die arbeitsplatte 10 cm
kürzen müsst kostet die küche euch
vielleicht 1000 euro mehr
weil sie sagen mir nötig so war das
nicht geplant und tut uns leid im
internet wirklich generell keine küche
bestellt
ich meine es sich ja nicht irgendwie so
einen blog zum drauf schreiben sondern
das ist eine küche in der arbeiten müsst
ihr müsst mal dran steht ihr müsst die
schublade öffnen die schränke öffnen ihr
müsst einfach gucken passe ich überhaupt
zu der küche oder passt die küche zu mir
und deswegen würde ich im internet kauft
vorbei küchen sowieso immer generell
ablehnen und mein letzter tag es nochmal
auf unterstützt eure händler vor ort das
hat nicht nur den vorteil dass jetzt die
wirtschaft eures ortes etwas unterstützt
und den händler vor ort unterstützt
sondern auch bei uns war so wir haben
dem händler gesagt wir hätten gerne
küche war eben und es sofort mittels
mitgegangen hat die küche ab gemessen
wird irgendwas ist dann kommen die in
der regel auch schnell und ihr müsst
nicht warten bis die irgendwo her bis
irgendwoher ein techniker oder ein
handwerker kommen man sagt ja auch immer
geh nicht fort und in diesem sinne war
das eigentlich schon beim küchen video
und erwartet jetzt in nächster zeit und
des werdens versprochen bald kommen wird
mein organisations video kommen sobald
ich eine system immer der küche habe es
werden meine werkzeuge kommen die ich
gut und schlecht finde es werden die
küchenmaschinen endlich vorgestellt die
ich jetzt lange zeit getestet habe und
natürlich gibt es ganz viele leckere
rezepte und ich freue mich einfach aufs
nächste mal wieder schreibt mir unten in
die infobox ob ich gerade beim
küchenplaner seit ob ihr euch hier
gekauft habt vielleicht habt ihr mal
gute oder schlechte erfahrungen gemacht
und können sie mit uns teilen
da würde ich mich auf jeden fall darüber
freuen und jetzt und ich auch den einen
oder anderen tipp geben da freue ich
mich auch darüber wenn ihr mir dann
feedback gibt ob euch dieses video
geholfen hat und ich wünsche euch allen
einen ganz ganz schönen tag des balls